hello how are you greetings natalia lancelot
and with informative envelope from iu it is nothing
in spanish what started as a
fire ended as an operation of
an illegal marijuana plantation residence
this happened on sunday in
spring valley a neighbor called the
fire department later  noticing sparks from the
electric meter when
firefighters and authorities arrived they
found
812 marijuana plants neighbors
said they rarely saw anyone
inside the property
narcotics detectives are investigating
this incident
the clark county school district
will face a  legal and
financial agreement during a meeting Thursday
of the school board members
will discuss the approval of
a settlement for 9 million dollars so
this is due to the case of
school bus driver mike the bank he was
arrested in 2015 for  being a
sexual predator he is behind bars
serving his 35 year sentence l
Prices are through the roof snowy one
of the states with the highest
gasoline prices in the country california and hawaii
occupy the top positions today the
average gasoline price closed at 3.86
per gallon
this represents 40 cents more than the
national average according to triplay
for all the details go to
our page
together with the section in Spanish and now
we move on to the weather forecast
we will continue with pleasant temperatures
in the 70s for the rest of the
week we will again see some breezes
that could bring slight precipitation
for Tuesday the temperatures will drop  temperatures
at 60 for next week have a nice day
the table of lancelot greets you and with its
brief news today we now in
Spanish
[Music]